اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
السودان امام مفترق خطير توتر بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ينذر بمواجهه المسلحه وينسف
امال الاتفاق السياسي
بعد الاتفاق على استئناف الخدمات القنصليه
السعوديه وسوريا تبحثان سبل ايجاد حل
سياسي للازمه السوريه
الوثائق المسربه تكشف المزيد اخر
التسريبات البانتاجون يرجح استمرار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تكشف من وراء تسريب الوثائق شاب امريكي
حصل عليها خلال عمله في احدى القواعد
العسكريه
اهلا بكم توترات شبت في منطقه مروي في
الولايه الشماليه في السودان قد تنسف معها
امالا توقيع اتفاق لنقل السلطه شراره
اشتعلت بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع توشي بان خلافات خطيره بين الطرفين
تطفو بينهما قربى مروى حيث قرر الجيش نشر
قوات في المدينه تحسبا لاي انفلات امني قد
يدخل البلاد في منعطف خطير خاصه وان ذروه
هذا التوتر تفاقمت خلال الساعات الماضيه
مع وصول اكثر من 100 سياره من الدعم
السريع الى السور الذي انشاته قرب مطار
مروي لكن قوات الدعم السريع اكدت ان
وجودها ياتي في اطار تاديه المهام المناطه
بهم نافيه انها لم تنسق مع قياده القوات
المسلحه وبقيه القوات النظاميه الاخرى
وعلى وقع هذه التوترات في منطقه مروي في
الولايه الشماليه بالسودان حذر الجيش من
ان السودان يمر في منعطف خطير بعد حجز
الدعم السريع قوته داخل العاصمه وبعض
المدن مؤكدا ان تحركات قوات الدعم السريع
تمت من دون موافقه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومن دون تنسيق معها
وجب علينا ان ندقنا قوس الخطر
بان بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
وتزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن
هذه التحركات والانفتاحات تمت دون موافقه
قياده القوات المسلحه او مجرد التنسيق
معها
مما اثار الهلع والخوف في اوساط مواطنين
وفاقم من المخاطر الامنيه
وزاد من التوتر بين القوات النظاميه
بيان القوات المسلحه السودانيه ابدى عدم
الرغبه في نشوب الصراع المسلح واوضح ان
اعاده تمركز قوات الدعم السريع يخالف مهام
ونظام عملها وهو في تجاوز واضح للقانون
لم تنقطع محاولات القوات المسلحه في ايجاد
الحلول السلميه لهذه التجاوزات وذلك حفاظا
على الطمانينه العامه وعدم الرغبه في نشوب
صراع مسلح يقضي على الاخضر واليابس لان
هذه الانفتاحات واعاده تمركز القوات
يخالف مهام ونظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات لجان الامنيه
واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما الى المزيد من
الانقسامات والتوترات التي ربما تقود الى
انفراط عرض الامن بالبلاد
وفي مطلع الشهر الجاري كان الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني نبيل عبد الله قد اكد ان
التوقع او التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي
للعمليه السياسيه مرهون بوضع جداول زمنيه
لدمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش ويعد
تعثر الاتفاق على دمج قوات الدعم السريع
والمدن والمدى الزمني ابرز نقاط الخلاف
بينهما لا سيما وانا قوات الدعم السريع
تطالب بفتره الزمنيه للانتقال تصل الى عشر
سنوات وذكر الجيش السوداني ان تكون هذه
الفتره الانتقاليه لعامين قائلا انه لا
يمكن الدخول في انتخابات بوجود اكثر من
جيش واحد في البلاد
[موسيقى]
جيش واحد
شعب
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نزار
البقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار اذا يعني في
ظل هذه التوترات وفي ظل تحركات للدعم او
قوى الدعم السريع في الولايه الشماليه
وخصوصا في مدينه او منطقه ميراوي ما
التحركات المتوقعه والمرتقبه لقياده الجيش
وقياده قوات الدعم السريع
نعم يعني ساعات المقبله هي ساعات حاسمه في
عمر المشهد السياسي والمشهد الامني
والمشهد
اجتماعي هنا في السودان ذلك لاهميه
ولحساسيه هذه التحركات لقوات الدعم السريع
وتمركز الجيش وانفتاح الجيش في منطقه مروي
العسكريه بالولايه الشماليه هذه التطورات
واجزاء ما قال به الجيش السوداني صباح هذا
اليوم من ان البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير بعد
هذه التحركات لقوات الدعم السريع نترقب
نحن هنا في الخرطوم تحركات مكوكيه سواء
كانت داخل القياده العامه للجيش او داخل
قياده الدعم السريع هذا من جانب هنالك بعض
التحركات لبعض الفاعلين الدوليين وذلك
لخلق اجواء من التهدئه بعد حاله الاعتقان
التي استادت الاجواء الامنيه والعسكريه
خلال الساعات الماضيه ربما يكون هنالك
تحرك للفاعلين الدوليين لمنظومه لبعض
السفارات هنا في الخرطوم لبعض القوى
السياسيه المكونه المدني القوى الحريه
والتغيير حزب الامه القومي كل هذه القوى
السياسيه الان تنظر بعين الترقب وتتخوف من
ان تنهار العمليه السياسيه التي بدات منذ
الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي بالتالي الان
الكل يترقب ما هي الحلول ما هي مسارات
الحل انفراج هذه الازمه التي وصلت الى
مستوى عالي من الحساسيه بين قياده الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه
مرتقب بين الجانبين هل بدا هذا الاجتماع
هل هناك بوادر لاي حل حلالي الازمه
الحاصله
يعني حتى اللحظه لم يكون هنالك اي معلومات
حول التوقيت الزماني لانعقاد هذا الاجتماع
اجتماع مجلس الامن والدفاع وهو يدوم يضم
القياده العليا في الجيش والمؤسسه الامنيه
والعسكريه والشرطيه وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا الاجتماع من المفترض ان يناقش
الحيثيات والتداعيات والقرارات التي يجب
ان تتخذ لوضع جديد يتعلق بمهام قوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان هنالك اتفاق سياسي وهنالك
عمليه سياسيه ارتات ان يتم دمج قوات الدعم
السريع عليه فان هذا الاجتماع له اهميه له
حساسيه له درجه من الاهميه لانه سيضع
الامور في نصابها وسيحدد كيف ستمضي الامور
خلال الساعات المقبله خاصه اذا اشرنا الى
ان قوات الدعم السريع كانت قد تلقت
معلومات من قبل الجيش السوداني بضروره ان
يتم الانسحاب من قاعده مروي العسكريه وهو
ما لم يتم حتى اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها
نزار الانباء تتحدث عن مبادرات امميه
واقليميه وجهود تحدث خلف الكواليس هل من
انباء حول ذلك
نعم يعني على الصعيد المحلي والصعيد
السياسي الان حزب الامه القومي ينشد عبر
رئيسه الجنرال فضلا لبرمه ناصر الرجل الان
قال قبل قليل بانه سيجد وسيبحث اي مسار
يفضي الى حلحله الازمه السياسيه والازمه
السودانيه والازمه الراهنه بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني مساء هذا
اليوم ايضا هنالك منتدا اعلامي لمجموعه
المجلس المركزي بقوه الحريه والتغيير مؤكد
بان الظلال ما حدث يوم امس واليوم بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع سيكون
حاضرا بحسبان ان العمليه السياسيه مرتبطه
ارتباطا وثيقا وجديا بمستوى التفاهمات بين
الجيش وبين قوات الدعم السريع ايضا من
الانباء التي لم تصدر حتى الان بان هنالك
تحركات ربما تكون الاليه الثلاثيه باعتبار
انها ايضا ميسره لعمليه سياسيه ومن
مصلحتها ان تكون الاجواء مهيئه لعقد اتفاق
سياسي بين الفرقه السودانيين شكرا لك من
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه نزار البداوي
[تصفيق]
مستمرون بعد الفاصل ونتابع
بخموت المعارك مشتعله والتضارب مستمر حول
من يسيطر على الجزء الاكبر من المدينه
اهلا بكم من جديد عقد وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان جلسه
مباحثات مع نظيره السوري فيصل المقداد في
جده وصدر بيان مشترك اكد ان المباحثات
ناقشت تحقيق تسويه في سوريا لعودتها الى
محيطها العربي وكذلك سبل ايجاد حل سياسي
يحافظ على وحده سوريا واكد البيان المشترك
على اهميه حل الصعوبات الانسانيه في سوريا
وايجاد الوسائل المناسبه لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه البيان السعودي شدد على دعم
الدوله السوريه لبسط سيطرتها وانهاء تواجد
الميليشيات المسلحه وكذلك شدد على تعزيز
التعاون بشان مكافحه تهريب المخدرات كما
رحب الجانبان ببدء اجراءات استئناف
الخدمات القنصليه والرحلات الجويه بين
سوريا والسعوديه بدوره اعرب وزير خارجيه
سوريا عن تقديره لجهود السعوديه لانهاء
الازمه السوريه وثمن جهود السعوديه على
تقديم ها المساعدات الانسانيه
لمتضرر الزلزال
كابوس دبلوماسي ترجو الولايات المتحده ان
تستفيق منه لكن هل يعقل ان يكون وراءه شاب
لم يتعدى من عشره بل انه كذلك صحيفه
واشنطن بوست الامريكيه كشفت معلومات عن
المسؤول عن تسريب وثائق ديسكورد وقالت ان
رجلا يدعى او جي نشرها العام الماضي حينها
قال لزملائه في المجموعه التي يتزعمها انه
حصل عليها خلال عمله في قاعده عسكريه لم
يحددها وبحسب الصحيفه فان معظم الذين
شاركهم اوجيل وثائق والبالغ عددهم نحو 20
فردا معظمهم من الرجال والشباب يشتركون
بحبهم لثلاثه حب البنادق والمعدات
العسكريه والله ونقل عن اوجي فان العديد
من تلك الوثائق نسخها بخط اليد لانها
موجوده في اماكن يحضر على داخلها حمل
الهواتف او الاجهزه الالكترونيه
وفي اخر ما كشفت عنه الوثائق المسربه فيما
يتعلق بحرب اوكرانيا مشاهدينا كشفت صحيفه
نقلا عن الوثائق ان استخبارات البنتا لا
ترجح بدء محادثات سلام بين موسكو وكيف بل
على العكس التوقعات اشارت الى مواصله رفض
الطرفين لاي تفاوض ينهي الصراع العام
الجاري اما السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا وذلك
وفق خبراء البنتاجون فهو استمرار النزاع
من دون اكتساب اي ميزه حاسمه لروسيا او
حتى لاوكرانيا هذا العام الوثائق
الامريكيه المسربه تضمنت ايضا احتماليه
مواصله اجراء التعبئه في كييف
كشفت وثائق البنتاجون المسربه عن وصول
الخسائر البشريه في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الى اكثر من 350 الف شخص خلال
المعارك بين قتيل وجريح وفقا لوكاله انباء
رويترز الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه تضمنت
ايضا توقعات بتحول الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني الى حرب طويله قد تستمر الى ما
بعد عام 20 23
ومن الوثائق الى ارض المعركه فلا تزال
مخمود تشهد القتال الاعنف في الشرق
الاوكراني وعلى واقع التصعيد تشهد الجبهه
تضارب في التصريحات بالسيطره عليها حيث
اعلنت قوات فاجنر الروسيه الاستيلاء على
اكثر من 80% من المدينه الا ان الجيش
الاوكراني الشرقي خرج ليانقض او لينقض هذا
التصريح الروسي ويؤكد سيطرته على اكثر
بكثير من 20% من مدينه باخموت واتهم قوات
فاجنر بالكذب لاظهار نوعا من الانتصار على
الاقل في تلك المدينه
وفي ظل هذه التضارب اشاد الرئيس الاوكراني
بجهود القوات المدافعه عن باخموت ومناطق
اخرى في الشرق هذا وافادت هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان
المحاولات الروسيه للسيطره على باخموت لم
تتوقف حيث صدت القوات الاوكرانيه قرابه 18
هجوما و14 هجوما على بلده مارينكا قرب
مدينه افديفكا كما حاولت القوات الروسيه
التقدم الى قريتين في الشمال الغربي لكن
من دون جدوى وفق هيئه الاركان العامه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك معنا رائد اذا ما زال
الحديث والانباء تتحدث بشكل كبير عن بخموت
والمعارك الضاريه هناك ما الانباء لديك
حولها
نهارك طيب فاطمه بالفعل معارك شرسه وداريه
تستعر خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وحتى هذه
اللحظه منذ الصباح الباكر لم تتوقف اصوات
المدافع
والصواريخ التي تطلق وتسقط في ذات الحين
ذلك لان يوم امس
اعتبر ذكرى اطلاق اول رصاصه للانفصاليين
في الثاني عشر من ابريل نيسان من عام 2014
ذلك ما جعل يعني رفع وتيره الاعمال
العسكريه من قبل الطرفين الاوكراني
وروسي هاجس كبير من اجل تكريس ذكرى هذا
اليوم وهو ذكرى الانفصال
يعني للانفصاليين عن اوكرانيا
باخمت معركه باخمت هي الاكثر سخونه حتى
الان 24 ساعه الماضيه شهدت معارك ضاريه
وشرسه بالف خاصه في وسط المدينه تقدمت
قوات فاغنر الى منطقه سكك الحديديه وسيطرت
على اجزاء من المحطات منها محطه باخمه
اثنان كما انها سيطرت على صوامع الحبوب في
المنطقه الغربيه من المدينه تتقدم قوات
فاجنر الى المنطقه الغربيه التي كانت
تعتبر محرمه على القوات الروسيه لتمركز
القوات الاوكرانيه فيها كما انها سيطرت
على عده شوارع اهم الشارع الرئيسي وهو
التاسع من مايو بالفعل هناك تقدم حسب
المعلومات الرسميه التي اعلن عنها مستشار
القائم باعمال الرئاسه هنا في دانيسك
لقوات باغنر في محور باقمت بعد ان سيطرت
كما اسلفت على 80% من الارض مقاومه شرسه
ايضا من الجانب الاوكراني المقاتلات
الروسيه نفذت تسع غارات جويه ضربت فيها
قواعد عسكريه اوكرانيه في محاور مختلفه
اهم المح ور الجنوبي والشرقي كما ان
المعارك مستعره في مدن اخرى هناك قصف شديد
بالفعل فاطمه لا نعلم اذا كان قريب من وسط
المدينه
هناك معارك في مدن اخرى
ايضا ارتفاع مدينه باخ موت هل ادى ربما
الى تخفيف الضغط وتخفيف التركيز على
المناطق الاخرى في الشرق الاوكراني
بالعكس ارتفعت وتيره الاعمال العسكريه في
كل منطقه على حده لا بد من ان نعرف
المشاهد بان طريقه عمل الجيش الروسي
مختلفه نوعا ما عن الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يعتبر جيش بوحد روسيا هي اتحاد روسيا
وفيدرالي فلذلك تعمل قوات فاغنر على سبيل
المثال في محور باخمه بينما عملت القوات
الشيشانيه في محور مدينه ماريوبل هناك
مدينه افديفيكا يتسلم المهام العسكريه في
مدينه افديفيكا
مقاتلي جمهوريه افخاذيا وابخازيا هي التي
انفصلت عن جورجيا قبل اكثر من عشره سنوات
والمقاتلين الابخازيين هم الذين
ينفذون عمليات اقتحام مستمره في مدينه
افديفكا ارتفعت العمليات العسكريه هناك
ايضا خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه وشهدت ايضا
غارات لسلاح الجو الروسي في
لم تسجل اي دخول الى المدينه هناك محاولات
فعليه للسيطره ولو على جزء بسيط
ليعتبر تقدم للجيش الروسي في مدينه بينما
سجلت القوات الروسيه او القوات المتطوعه
الروسيه في مدينه مارينكا المتاخمه سيطر
على احد الاحياء في المنطقه الغربيه وهو
تطور لم يحدث منذ عده اشهر حيث كان هناك
يعني فطور او عدم تقدم للقوات الروسيه بعد
ان سيطرت على ثلثي مدينه مارينكا سيطرت
على حي
فادينو في المنطقه الغربيه بينما يعتبر
المحور الجنوبي وهو محور مدينه اوغلادار
ساكنا نوعا ما وهناك يعني انتظار او ترقب
لعوده اوكرانيه حيث هناك تسريبات بان
الجيش الاوكراني يحشد للعوده على المدن
القريبه من مدينه اوغلادار في ذلك المحور
شكرا لك من دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر
يا اوكرانيا بان الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لاوكرانيا انخفض بنسبه 29%. 1 في عام 20
22 ولم يذكر سبب الانخفاض في حين ان
الحكومه قالت ان السبب الرئيسي لتراجع
الناتج المحلي هو العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الذي ادى الى خساره او خساره جزء
كبير من اوكرانيا وبالتالي اضرار لحقت
بصناعه
كشف الصحفيه الامريكيه الشهير سيمون هرش
عن اوجه مختلفه للفساد داخل نظام الرئيس
الاوكراني
عبر مقاله الاخير هرش نقل عن مصادر له في
الاستخبارات الامريكيه حقائق تتهم بالفساد
واستغلال الحرب بطرق عده نتابع
الصحفي الاكثر جدلا يعود مجددا كاشفا عن
قضايا ساخنه فبعد ان اتهم امريكا بتفجير
خط الغاز نورد ستريم يعود ويضع الرئيس
الاوكراني في دائره اتهام بالفساد ما هي
الا رساله من المخابرات الامريكيه وضعت
زينينسكي بين فكيهرش
رساله سريه بين مدير وكاله المخابرات
الامريكيه ويليامبرز والرئيس الاوكراني
تتضمن قائمه لعشرات المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
الفاسدين بينهم زيلينسكي
التجاره مع العدو عنوان مقاله هرش تشير
بالارقام الى تعاون زيلينسكي مع عدوته
روسيا من خلال شراء الوقود من المساعدات
الامريكيه وهو ما وصفه هرش بالاحتيال
المالي
قال لي احد مسؤولي المخابرات الامريكيه
المطلعين كنزكي يشتري الوقود بسعر منخفض
من الروس ومن يدفع ثمن الغاز والنفط نحن
الامريكيون بوتين وحكومته يكسبون الملايين
من ذلك حيث دفع الفينتاجون ما يقدر ب 400
مليون دولار للعمل الماضي
كشف احد مسئولي المخابرات لهرج ايضا
النازيلينسكي متهم فيما يعرف بتجاره الحرب
والسلاح واكثر من ذلك انشاء شركات وهميه
بهدف ابرامي عقود مع تجار اسلحه حول
العالم قيل لي ان العديد من الوزارات
الحكوميه في كييف كانت تتنافس حرفيا
لانشاء شركات واجهه لعقود تصدير الاسلحه
والذخيره مع تجار الاسلحه المستقلين في
جميع انحاء العالم يوجد العديد من هذه
الشركات في بولندا وتشيكو اسرائيل
كان الضغط الامريكي وراء حمله مكافحه
الفساد في اوكرانيا قبل اربعه اشهر وفق
هرش حيث قدمت امريكا قائمه من 35 مسؤولا
اوكرانيا فاسدا وطلبت اقالتهم لكن
زيلينسكي اكتفى باقاله عشره فقط
مقاله هرش لن يمر مرورا عاديا فهو ذاته
الذي كشف عن تورط المخابرات الامريكيه
بتفجير انبوب نورد ستريم تعرض هرش بعدها
لهجوم كبير من الاداره الامريكيه حيث اتهم
بانه عنصر في الدعايه الروسيه غذاء السالم
العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
فرنسا تتاهب لليوم الثاني عشر من
الاحتجاجات على مشروع قانون التقاعد
بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
السودان امام مفترق خطير توتر بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ينذر بمواجهه المسلحه وينسف
امال الاتفاق السياسي
بعد الاتفاق على استئناف الخدمات القنصليه
السعوديه وسوريا تبحثان سبل ايجاد حل
سياسي للازمه السوريه
الوثائق المسربه تكشف المزيد اخر
التسريبات البانتاجون يرجح استمرار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تسريب الوثائق شاب امريكي حصل عليها خلال
عمله في احدى القواعد العسكريه
احييكم من جديد افادت وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه عبور 14 طيران صينيا للخط
الاوسط لمضيق تايوان خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه وبحسب الوزاره تضمنت
الطائرات مقاتلات سوثرتي وجي 60 وجي 10
يذكر ان الصين تقوم باجراء تدريبات عسكريه
وتدريبات حول تايوان التي تدعي بكين انها
جزء من اراضيها
افادت كوريا الجنوبيه بان كوريا الشماليه
اطلقت نوعا جديدا من الصواريخ البالستيه
متوسطه المدى يعمل على الارجح بالوقود
الصلب واعتبرت سول اطلاق صواريخ او او
صاروخ حلق لمسافه 1000 كيلو متر تقريبا
يعتبر استفزازا خطيرا اما اليابان فاطلقت
تحذيرا لسكان جزيره هوكايدو الشماليه ثم
سحبته لاحقا وقالت ان نظام الطوارئ اعتقد
ان الصاروخ سيسقط بالقرب منها
وصل الرئيس الامريكي السابق الى منهات
للايداع امام نيويورك بحسب المدعي العام
جيمز شوهد ترامب وهو يدخل برج ترامب وسط
تواجد امنيه خارج المبنى وتم تقديم اقوال
ترامب من قبل المدعي العام في نيويورك
ورفع جيمز دعوى قضائيه ضد ترامب وثلاثه من
ابنائه البالغين ومنظمه ترامب واخرين في
سبتمبر الماضي بعد تحقيق استمر لثلاث
سنوات
جددت النقابات العماليه في فرنسا دعوتها
الى اضرابات ومسرات لليوم الثاني عشر
احتجاجا على نظام المعاشات التقاعديه
اهمها الاضراب المفتوح لعمال النظافه
وعوده مشاهد تلال النفايات واشارت
التوقعات الى ان اعداد المشاركين سيتراوح
ما بين
400,600 الف شخص في مختلف انحاء البلاد
ومن المقرر نشر 11,500 شرطي
و4,200 منهم في العاصمه باريس
بعدما اقر البرلمان المصري تعديلات لا
تسمحوا لضباط الشرطه بالاستقاله الا بعد
قضاء عشر سنوات في الخدمه يحاول احد
النواب الان تطبيق نفس التعديل على طلاب
كليه الطب السبب هو حمايه القطاع الصحي من
تسرب الاطباء الى الخارج بينما يرى
الاطباء انه من الاولى تحسين ظروف الاطباء
اولا
هل يمكن مساواه ضباط الشرطه بالاطباء
لناحيه شروط الاستقاله هذا ما يطالب به
احد النواب في محاوله لمنع استقالات
الاطباء الشباب التي تؤدي لعجز في
المنظومه الصحيه
النائب عاطف مغاوري يدافع عن مقترحه بعدم
قبول الاستقاله الا بعد قضاء عشر سنوات في
مستشفيات الدوله او دفع ثلاثه اضعاف
تكاليف الدراسه الجامعيه رابط الشرطه لما
بيستقيل بيستقيل بحثا عن تحقيق مصلحه
وانفعه اعلى من وجوده كضابط شرطه فهو
يستقيل ايضا الطبيب يستقيل هيستقيل لانه
يرى في نفسه سواء هيعمل مستشفيات خاصه او
هيعمل لدى الخارج فهو بيقرر الاستقامه اذا
بحثا عن ميزه امام هذه الميزه انا انفقت
عليك على الجانب الاخر ترى نقابه الاطباء
ان الانفاق على طالب الكليات العسكريه من
اقامه واعاشه وتعليم يختلف تماما عن
الانفاق على طلاب كليه الطب اضافه الى عدم
مساواه في الرواتب والمزايا الوظيفيه بين
الفريقين بعد التخرج كلنا عايزين نعيش في
البلد دي
طب انت دور سيدي البرلمان على اسباب اللي
خلت الراجل ده يستقيل الخلت الراجل ده
يقدم على هجره ويسافر للهجره والا احنا
ممكن بعد فتره هيحصل تصحر طبي الامر لم
يكن غائبا عن اطباء المستقبل الذين
وجدناهم متابعين لهذا الخبر وتباينت نحوه
ردود فعلهم وان كانت الغالبيه منهم تعرضه
لانهم بالفعل يفكرون في السفر شايفه ناس
معايا في الجامعه من سنه اولى بيفكروا في
عمل معادله والسفر بره طب ليه يعني طبعا
هي فكره حلوه لان احنا عندنا عجز كبير قوي
يعني احنا محتاجين فعلا اطباء احنا كل
الكوادر الطبيه الكويسه بتطلع بره
منطقيه يعني هو مش جيش وغير كده كده انت
بمجرد ما بتتخرج او مش بتتخرج سنه خمسه او
سته انت بتشتغل في الامتياز احنا عندنا
نظام سنتين سياسي كده كده هتخدم البلد
فى شايفها ان ممكن تكون ثقيله ممكن ممكن
اوافق لو مده تبقى اقل هذا الاقتراح اللي
انا يعني طرحته ومتبني لن يناقش ولن
يستكمل الا في ظل منظومه منها منها فكره
القانون المسئوليه الطبيه ومنها ايضا كادر
الطب
والمرتبات طلاب الطب يعلمون يقينا بالظروف
العمل الحكومي قبل دخول الكليه وهو ما
يستند اليه النائب في مقترحه ولكن في
الوقت نفسه يرى اخرون انه يحق لهم البحث
عن الحياه الكريمه التي تعب دراسيا من
اجلها تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره في ليبيا
اجواء ثقافيه وفنيه تعيشها للمدينه
القديمه في طرابلس في ليالي رمضان
واستقبال كبير من سكان العاصمه لزيارتها
بعد اعمال الصيانه الاخيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هكذا هي الاجواء ليلا داخل ازقه المدينه
القديمه بطرابلس التي تقام على ارضها
فعاليات ليالي المدينه بعد صيانه هزاع
منها وتحويلها من مكان مهمل لسنوات طويله
الى مقصد للعائلات والشباب في ليالي رمضان
مثل هذه النشاطات لا شك بان ترس الرساله
بان ليبيا على طريق الاستقرار ان قطعنا
شوط طويل في هذا المسار نحو الاستقرار
اكثر من 600 منشط ثقافي وفني تسعى اللجنه
المنظمه لتقديمه لزوار المدينه تنوعت بين
عروض راجله تحاكي فيها تاريخ الجهاز
الليبي ومسرح للطفل وندوات ثقافيه
بالاضافه الى الحكوات التي يقص القصص
للاطفال وفقرات للتعريف بالشخصيات
التاريخيه الليبيه حقيقه هو الهدف منها
تحريك لعجله الفن والثقافه والابداع
بالاضافه الى لدينا حركه اقتصادي تحريك
العاجزه الاقتصاديه اقبال كبير على زياره
المدينه والمشاركه في الانشطه الترفيهيه
من مختلف الاعمار التي تستمر حتى ساعات
الصباح الاولى وسط تامين مشدد من رجال
الامن
تاريخ الا المدينه القديمه نرجعوا له
تاريخ مشرف تاريخ فيه بطولات الناس كلها
تطلع من بيوتها تطلع زهريات في حياه ليله
في ليبيا على الاقل في طرابلس
بصراحه المدينه قديمه بدت معلم
مزار ومش عادي اصبحت العاصمه ترابزيه
العواصم العربيه اللي تحتفي بشهر رمضان
وخاصه مع الجو الربيعي الان يعود عمر بعض
المباني هنا الى اكثر من 500 عام عانت
الاهمال لسنوات طويله حتى بدا بعض اجزائها
بالسقوط قبل التدخل الحكومي الاخير
لصيانتها وتحويلها الى مزار سياحي ليالي
المدينه القديمه في طرابلسا مختلفه هذا
العام حيث اصبحت المدينه مقصدا للزوار
الراغبين في الترويح عن انفسهم متجاهلين
الصراعات السياسيه التي حرمتهم من مثل هذه
الاجواء لسنوات طويله منير الاشهب طرابلس
العربيه
الاعمال الخليجيه في شهر رمضان هذا العام
نافست بقوه وحققت نجاحا مهما حيث ظهرت
افكار مختلفه وتم طرح قصص جديده دارت في
شغل جغرافيا الخليج او حتى خارجه مقدمه
حكايات ملفته تستحق التوقف عندها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سيارتي الروز والله ما تردها والله
مرحبا لم يكن مسلسل طاش ما طاش جماهيريه
مطالب بالعوده بجديد الجمهور كان مكتفي
مبدئيا بفكره عود ثنائيه ناصر القصبي وعبد
الله السدحان للعمل ليس ذلك وحسب والعوده
بعد النجوم ممن كانوا مبتعدين خاصه يوسف
الجراح وفهد الحيان وغيرهم الا انه كان
ينتظر ان يعود العمل بقصص وحكايه وقضايا
تشبه ما يعيش اليوم واقع مختلف تماما
بالطبع عن الماضي وهو ما كان فريق العمل
ليحرص عليه طوال فتره التحذير يعني هذا
اكثر شيء يشغلنا انك انت شلون شلون ترجع
الجو
العام حق طاش شخصيات بافكار البسيطه هذا
اكثر شيء كان شاغلنا
واتوقع ان احنا يعني
لمسنا هذا الجو يعني
رحنا الجو
خفيف
حاولنا نركز على الجو الشعبي
العمر جدا الذي يتابع بحب واهتمام وينتظر
المزيد انا شعدت بكثير من الحلقات اللي
قدمناها نعم احنا
قعدنا واخذنا واعطينا في ورشه النص انا
سعيد بالشخصيات اللي قدمتها وكذلك سعيد
بالشخصيات اللي قدمها ناصر والزملاء اللي
شاركونا هذا
العمل هذا عمل سهل سهل صعب ماني عارف ابوي
كنت اقول انا كاني في حلم
صدقا كاني في حلم لانها المكتوب على الورق
صعب صعب والحمد لله تيسر
بنسبه مشاهده عاليه اردنا ان نعرف لماذا
تم الناس بالعمل لهذه الدرجه وما رايهم
بالجزء الجديد منه فنزلنا اليهم وسالنا
حميده لهم نصر القصوى وعبد الله السدحان
ويعني احنا كلنا مشتاقين لهم وبعد غياب
طويل بصراحه عوده جدا جدا جميله اسعدت
اتوقع مو بس الشعب السعودي الخليج كامل
هذولي يعني
جيل الطيبين وذكرات مره حلوه الطفوله
قديمه وجددوا لنا الذكرى الثنائيه كبيره
تربينا عليهم ونحن صغار
وشفنا بدايتهم كانت قويه السنه هذه
ونتمنى ان شاء الله يمتعونا في الحلقات
القادمه
[تصفيق]
الى العناوين
بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
السودان امام مفترق خطير توتر بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ينذر بمواجهه المسلحه وينسف
امال الاتفاق السياسي
بعد الاتفاق على استئناف الخدمات القنصليه
السعوديه وسوريا تبحثان سبل ايجاد حل
سياسي للازمه السوريه
الوثائق المسربه تكشف المزيد اخر
التسريبات الفانتوجون يرجح استمرار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
و واشنطن فوز تكشف من وراء تسريب الوثائق
شاب امريكي حصل عليها خلال عمله في احدى
القواعد العسكريه
كنتم مع نشره مفصله اتتكم من العربيه زميل
نايف الاحمري القاكم على راس الساعه الى
ذلك الحين في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات